okay Myron
uh I'm a professional misogynist
right love by some hated by many just on
the internet yeah on the internet yeah
we're both on the Internet it's a
strange life yeah I feel like okay this
is an observation and I'm not trying to
roast anyone I just have observations I
feel like when we've been on the
Internet or too long I have this problem
too our posture just starts to go
it just starts to
I have the same problem same issue seen
some videos
you're not a fan of me are you you know
I'm not a fan of many things yeah you
just happen to be in there maybe a
little bit why is that we disagree on
some things I think we might get on
though that's why I'm like interested
off to a great start he takes me I think
it's very important to be able to
articulate your views and if you don't
agree with someone it doesn't mean you
have to hate them but you know but I
think being too agreeable is not good
really especially as a man because
typically if a guy is too agreeable you
can't trust them living yeah why because
all men want to get laid and if you
don't tell the truth and you're just
being agreeable well he's trying to get
laid and he's trying to lie as well so
well at least the man actually admits
all men are trying to get laid oh yeah
100 yeah I mean that's just common sense
duh
how bad is my dog snoring in the chat
how bad is my dog snoring in the chat
absolutely pointless to have a female
friend no no it's not a pointless to
have a female friend very pointless 100
why would guys sit there and be friends
with girls it's pointless stupid so you
don't have any female friends absolutely
not it's a waste of time how is that
waste of time because women don't offer
much utility to you as a guy what makes
you think that
well I mean if you get in some kind of
fight she can't do nothing what you're
going to do to me oh my God
if anything she's a liability that's
what I'm trying to say like I'd fight a
woman for you if you're my man I don't
want my girl to be involved in any type
of physical conversation that's that's
not her job that's my job so I look at
it like if I'm with a girl and I'm
supposed to protect her and provide for
her Etc I want that to be my woman I'm
not going to give that type of energy to
like a friend that's stupid why am I
going to put my life on the line for a
girl that doesn't even suck my dick wait
but is that too much there I don't I
think you should just be able to have a
friendship with women though well well
firstly it's not always like men versus
women so I kind of feel like having
female friends will give you that
balance to understand like there's
actually nice normal women okay
is there any utility to female friends
hmm
as a guy I mean
it just depends I mean some guys
Ellie
they use the friends as like
pre-selection to get laid and that's how
they do it I think they argue that's not
an effective way because all the girls
know their friend zone but I'm like ah
I don't know I've seen
um like I can think of two people that
are dating right now that met through me
because I was friends with the girl and
the guy
so you know some people yes sometimes I
don't know aren't just trying to sleep
with you like for your money or
everything like that we bring a lot of
value
I've interviewed almost 1600 women now
at this point and I would say without a
shout out without women are absolutely
terrible at being understanding what it
takes to be attractive to women as a man
yeah that's true we have no idea oh my
God
should I kick my dog out let me know in
the chat should I kick my dog out of my
room
one or two one or two in the chat
[Music]
um
one or two in the chat should I kick my
dog out I I can't tell how loud it is
for you guys but
yeah I would say
viewing the show for six months no women
have no idea what women like
like none none none
other advice typically is not good at
all one thousand six hundred women
four women men carry like a lot of like
hurt and they push it on women okay her
in what way yeah I think it's because
like for example this Enzo culture which
like respectfully like your podcast
really brings to life you're just
projecting onto women unnecessarily
because there's a lot of good women like
I myself would say I'm a good woman I
don't do anything wrong I'm very loyal
I'm a kind woman and a lot of men will
make the Assumption I've actually talked
to Cheyenne a little bit
um she's actually very nice she's very
nice I don't she's not the exact way she
is on camera
um I'd like to say she's very nice
hold on okay because of podcast like
yours and people and men like you to
then push that one to me I'm this kind
of woman I'm a gold digger and I'm
Memphis and that and I'm not no no but
this is this is the thing like
you might be kind and you might be loyal
for the right guy but like the thing is
our nature is the same and the West is
still the West so even if you're a nice
woman you're still in the west and
you're still a modern woman
um yeah
well the reality is would it be fair to
say that most men I mean you said
there's a whole insult culture Etc would
it be fair to say that most guys are
losers and don't don't really measure up
I personally don't think that wow
genuinely I don't okay okay politically
correct I'll keep it real since you
don't want to most guys I'll be honest
are fat losers and don't have leadership
qualities and there's a whole bunch of
reasons for that and most women quite
frankly are terrible they're [ __ ] fat
rude crass whatever it may be and most
of them don't qualify for relationship
and most guys don't qualify to be the
leader of set relationships I think it
goes on both parts okay the men are weak
and the women there's a bunch of issues
there I agree I agree I do think
women caused those issues
men like by and large are the same
they're just like less motivated almost
because it's like
the juice isn't really worth the squeeze
anymore oh well we basically highlight
on our podcasters need to be the best
version of yourself and I think the
thing is is that guys are yearning for
this because we've been lying to men for
the better part of five to six decades
about what being masculine and strong
actually is we've been demonizing it
when in reality guys need to become
stronger because no woman wants a weak
man Even though girls say dumb [ __ ] like
oh well you know I want you to be
emotionally intelligent get in tune real
feelings or whatever it's all a lie okay
no there's a but I personally would like
a man that's emotionally available
and emotionally intelligent but it's not
me saying like I want you crying all the
time so I mean it's true though like so
I understand what you're saying but at
the same time you have to give some room
for men because yeah like see this is
what I mean like when women we don't
understand
what when like what makes men attractive
to women like
it's not to say you can never ever ever
cry or be emotionally available to your
girl ever but the point that men are
making is that you only have so much
before she's disgusted by it and each
girl is different and you don't know
what your girl is
FaceTime and it is a blessing calling me
again
see okay I'm gonna call him back I'm
gonna call him back
oh
yeah okay well
anyways yeah so that's my whole that's
my whole point yeah
is
you still wait hold on sorry mistake oh
the serious like issue we tell guys not
to be vulnerable in front of your girl
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible